you know I want to say that while I
agree with I'm I'm with Senator Bennet
and others but I agree with almost
everything here I'll tell you one thing
it's really nice if you got all these
plans but if you think we're gonna beat
Donald Trump by just having all these
plans you got another thing coming
because he didn't win I think he had a
plan he won by simply saying make
America great again
we've got to get deeper than just these
superficial fixes as important as they
are even if we're just talking about the
superficial fixes ladies and gentlemen
we don't have a health care system in
the United States we have a sickness
care system in the United States we just
wait till somebody gets sick and then we
talk about who's going to pay for the
treatment and how they're going to be
treated what we need to talk about is
why so many Americans have unnecessary
chronic illnesses so many more compared
to other countries and that gets back
into not just the healthy Big Pharma
not just health insurance companies it
has to do with chemical policies it has
to do with environmental
[Applause]
the quaint